[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thank you for joining
me and Ryan Taos Ryan greetings hello hi
uh
I'm happy that you've chosen to listen
to this podcast today A lot of people
are um loyal listeners out there my
lovable patrons
that love the show and support it and
supporting it for years and um making it
possible for us to continue recording
and if you want to become a patron and
support the podcast if you like it and
you want to support a podcast you like
patreon.com inside of you
p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com slash inside of you
I'll send you a message there's a lot of
perks you get uh shout outs every
episode on the podcast you get uh to ask
questions and there's merch boxes and
zooms and YouTube lives and merch
discounts and a bunch of stuff it's
really a more more so a family oriented
platform for friends people who like a
community it's not just supporting the
podcast but it's a an amazing Community
I didn't really say that articulately
but I don't care
um just to tell you a few things before
you fast forward
um Tom and I will be in DC
uh September 27th and the weekend before
that we're in Salt Lake City we're doing
an event like the Tom and Michael show
and we read scripts and it's a blast get
tickets to those events you could go to
my link Tree on Instagram it's a link
and it will tell you everything I'm
doing cameos patreon uh and most
importantly I'd like to talk about the
live podcast if you like like the show
you want to support it or if you're in
the area in Los Angeles on October 11th
7 p.m at the Regent Theater
it's me and Zach Levi it's the inside of
you podcast live for the first time ever
so far tickets are doing all right we're
selling tickets nice you know oh I said
gosh I hope 50 people come but honestly
I mean if if 150 people came I'd be
happy right that'd be gone it'd be
awesome that'd be awesome man so look
get tickets there's also a meet and
greet with Zach and I if you want to
come to that it's October 11th 7 pm
get your tickets on the link Tree in my
bio
um and if you want to support this
podcast continue to do so the handles
Ryan at inside of you pod on Twitter
inside of your podcast on Instagram and
Facebook that's correct and you can
write a review which really helps the
algorithms and all that stuff
um great uh guest today in fact Bryce my
producer emailed me and said that this
was one of his favorites this is really
a kick-ass episode
and uh I don't I remember it being good
but I don't remember it being like
because when you're in it you don't
really think about that stuff in fact I
forget I forget everything yeah and uh
apparently we went really deep and
Anthony was so kind and what's funny is
he came here a week early
by accident goes hey uh Anthony I go I I
don't know what Anthony is Anthony
Anthony
hey hey hold on a second man I went
downstairs he's like yeah I'm ready for
the podcast I'm like yeah it's not till
next week goes oh all right I'll come
back okay you're gonna come back though
right he goes yeah
he's so cool and so like just he's just
got his own thing man I wish I was that
cool I wish I was half as cool as
Anthony Paglia I need a cool name like
Anthony lapaglia Michael Rosenbaum
but if you say it like that it sounds
cool Michael Rosenbaum Anthony lapaglia
in Michael Mann's This City never sleeps
I bet there's been a movie called that
all right um great episode I hope you
enjoy it we talk about everything
without a trace Empire Records uh
everything uh he's an open book and I
think you're gonna really like it so
without further Ado let's get inside of
Anthony Le Paglia it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode in any we air
before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
to be honest this is the first like real
kind of podcast I've ever done is that
true are we rolling did you hear that we
got that what he just said this is
really like the first podcast this is
the first podcast I've ever done
why
um
I don't know I don't know why I said yes
to you I think because of Larson
Thompson yes that's exactly why because
I really like her she's a good kid yeah
what did you work with it's tough though
because the guy I made the movie with
I've known him for 30 years the director
writer right and I did stuff with him
when I was very young
and um
I don't know as time went on
we stayed friends but I wasn't gonna do
this movie right but his actor
I was he asked me about someone else and
I was telling why y'all ask for you
Pearl he told me a bit about it but to
be honest the last time we had worked
together
it started to get a bit strained
Thai
I'm a Thai West the director was Bobby
Ross and look we uh we've been
we were friends for a good chunk of time
I was still friends but
stuff happens in life and
you kind of I don't know either you see
things more clearly or you see things
that you ignored before
you could say the same thing about me I
don't know he wouldn't he
he's an incredibly nice man but he's uh
oversharer
over you know he's an oversharer he
thinks that I don't need to know and the
things that like make it hard for me
you know and but hey it's just enough
share with me he has a Blog where he
overshares with everybody I've never
asked him about it when you say over
shares what do you mean because Ryan
when you say I overshare
no you you share you're open but I think
there I I think there's a line that you
don't cross right over this line gets
crossed yeah like like he's in Dragoon
he's a tap dancer in Dragoon he's like
um he's he overtakes everything and
he journals everything that happens and
some of it is like
bro just roll it back I mean I'm glad
you want your life to be an open book
but
it's like I've had to stop reading them
you tend them to everybody it'd be a big
blast out you know yeah is it one of
those things where like I remember I was
at Disney World with my my family and I
was videotaping everything everything
and my uncle goes why don't you just
enjoy real life this is my own thing
okay because I'm from a generation I'm
an old [__] now so you know yeah yeah
yeah it's 60 64 63. it looks good yeah
all right you know formaldehyde does
wonders and so he got me out of the vat
this morning and so um
you know I grew up in the era I don't
sound like that uh when I was growing up
they had the Model T but I grew up in an
era where there was no cell phones I
mean it wasn't a flip phone there was
there was your parents avocado green or
purple and orange phone with a rotary
and a long cord
and there's one line in yeah and you
know if I was on the phone with my old
man going home it was get off there was
no privacy and so
it's such a different world now
and I'm I'm I actually I look at it more
from like a science project because I
have a 20 year old daughter who's never
known
uh not having not having iPhones around
she's never known that I don't I think
you haven't have you I was born in 1988
so like okay all right you're not that
young person
20 years ago
um yeah she just turned 20. and then she
and so she doesn't know and so she would
genuinely sit there and say to me how
did you ever get anything I mean how did
you ever go to a party how did you ever
you know know what was going on I said I
was
I was young I was Dumb and I was really
happy I didn't know what was going on
yeah and somebody I run into somebody
well I was you know younger teenage or
whatever I'd run into somebody on the
street and they go hey there's a party
Friday night or Saturday night it's here
be there whatever and you just showed up
if I remembered because somewhere
between Tuesday and Saturday there were
so many other options I probably didn't
go or forgot it or whatever right but if
I did it I'm going
there were quite a few times you showed
up and the party wasn't there anymore
and and um uh and she said what would
you do I'd say well you know I just
whatever party was going on there wasn't
the original one but I would just go
into that
you know and just yeah chill out that
was the time there was something fun
about that like my friends would say hey
you want to go see that movie tonight
I'll meet you there at seven and you
hope they're there and sometimes they
don't show and that to me actually was
more exciting than the people I was
actually going to see I think and um but
this was when I was living in New York
right so a bit easier on the street
there so the jungle drums went out and I
lived in East Village West Village so
I'd always run into
somebody who knew somebody who was
throwing the party or or whatever event
it was or you know when I say party I
mean that's really kind of a loose term
it's basically a bowl of cocaine and
then uh you know this is 90s and 90s
really so that's you saw a lot of that
oh man everybody was doing it you know I
would walk into some place in fact if I
didn't know any if the people that
invited me weren't there it was no
problem because there would be oh
they're broke so
um a walk in there and nine times out of
ten they wouldn't be just like some
cocaine there there would be a bowl of
cocaine that looked like a little little
tip of Mount Everest in the middle of
the table and nobody was guarding it
it's like you just help yourself so you
did you got involved in the you you
could absolutely in fact when I left the
park it was bro so when I left the party
I would find a piece of paper somewhere
and fold it up and then kind of shave
the top of the bowl off put it into the
paper save it for later snacking
absolutely I absolutely would save it
for later or if somebody else a friend
of mine wanted some I wouldn't sell it
to them because I stole it was Stalin I
mean if I if I just stayed there long
enough I probably would have done it but
uh but did you have an addictive
personality were you someone who just
kind of did it when you did it but did
you ever have a problem do you know I
for many years I did not for many years
it's the same with the alcohol
um I I'm I even now
I can drink I don't drink that much
because I don't get that much enjoyment
out of it because I find it very hard to
get drunk
so I can drink
um three three quarters of bottle of
Mezcal and I'm fine and everyone is
around me I realize is completely [__]
up
because I drink it I drink it straight
up look I don't I don't and same with
vodka is that just the Australian blood
no what is it because I'm an eye tie you
know like I'm an Italian and Italians
are not notoriously big you know
not
competent drinkers
they're not they have a couple of
glasses of wine and they start crying
about their dead mother and
and all the things that went wrong in
their life they're very emotional and I
have a very even thing the thing with
cocaine that's really
for many years I was just a recreational
user if I could I couldn't afford it so
if I found it I would use it or whatever
I couldn't afford to actually buy the
stuff
um even back then when I think it was
like you know
a nickel a bag or something it was
pretty cheap
and and before and and at the risk of
sailing like such an old [__] but way
better all the drugs were way better
oh they're pure man I tried everything
you know heroin not it's the one I did
it accidentally I I it accidentally put
a needle in your head no no no no no it
was powdered right right and I was in a
dark room and it was kind of a beige
color and I didn't realize I thought it
was coke
how much did that mess you up it didn't
too much
I went to sleep
that's all I smoked heroin by accident
too I know everybody's thinking oh yeah
Anthony accidentally did it Michael
actually well I never did it again I
never did it I was afraid of that drug
but I did it I smoked something and
afterwards I started feeling really
weird and my buddy goes yeah they laced
it with a little heroin I go what and I
remember this sensation of like the best
feeling I've ever had and then it turned
into me puking on the streets well
that's what that's the thing it usually
it's the other way around you puke first
and then have the best feeling you've
ever had you seem to have the reverse
yeah well I I was always scared of
certain drugs like that yeah and it was
the needle aspect I don't like needles
no I don't like that you go down that
road I like drugs that are like but back
then you know like you had like a couple
choices you had Coke you had benzos and
you had um pot uh I never liked pot I
never smoked it
um whenever I smoke reason what happens
when I have because my daughter
he loves a puff and I've tried her stuff
for Jesus Christ this stuff is so strong
yeah I get so I'm paranoid I get
paranoid I get on the couch I pull the
blanket over my head and I lay there
till it's over yeah it's no fun
inside of you is brought to you by prize
picks if you are just uh you know
sitting around want to do something fun
testing of your knowledge you don't have
to know anything about sports really I
don't know anything about sports and yet
I'm winning money on this prize picks
and it's pretty
amazing prize picks listen to this I'll
get into what I'm doing here price picks
is the largest independently owned daily
fantasy sports platform in North America
one of the easiest and most exciting
ways to play it's just you against the
numbers instead of battling thousands of
other players including pros and sharks
you pick more
or less than on two to six players stat
projections and watch the winnings roll
in now what does that mean it's so easy
so the other day I had uh a picture I
picked two players a pitcher from one
team pitcher from the other team it said
do you think he'll get more or less than
four strikeouts I go ah I looked up his
dad he's not a very good pitcher I want
to say less than the other pitcher I go
oh I know that guy yeah yeah is like you
know his last start he had like a nine
strikeouts he's gonna go I'm gonna say
he's gonna go over that over the five or
four or whatever
I've won three times out of five
I'm rolling it's pretty incredible this
prize picks I'm having a lot of fun on
this and I know you will too prize picks
now offers Apple pay for quick and easy
deposits into your account this football
season uh price picks offers projections
on any sport that you watch includes
college football pro hockey basketball
the list goes on players can choose from
a vast selection of sports and Stat
types not offered anywhere else they can
even pick in-game projections after a
game has started which includes halves
quarters periods and more price picks is
the most fun you'll have winning up to
25 times your money this football season
you just select two or more players pick
more or less on their projected stats
and place your entry if you have the
skills you can turn 10 bucks into 250
bucks with just a few Taps I have the
app it's so simple I press it every once
in a while I go oh here are the sports I
like this sport let's go to the sport
boom I'm there and then I go oh let's
pick the pictures oh I don't want to go
runs in the first inning or it's all
there it's all simple and you could turn
your money into a lot more money and
it's fun I really love this thing and um
I hate you prize picks because I'm
really enjoying this how much have you
won so far
um let's see I start out with a hundred
and I'm at 210. nice yeah that's pretty
cool yeah I'll show it to you okay you
gotta you got to try this all right go
to prize picks.com inside and use code
inside for a first deposit match up to a
hundred dollars that's go to prize
picks.com slash inside use the code
inside for a first deposit match up to
one hundred dollars must be present in
certain States visit prize picks.com for
restrictions and details prize picks is
available to Residents 19 plus in so
many states like California Arkansas
Arizona the list goes on if you want to
have some fun it's time you choose prize
picks this message is sponsored by
discover did you know you could reduce
the number of unwanted calls and emails
with online privacy protection the
latest Innovation from discover discover
will help regularly remove your personal
info like your name and address from 10
popular people search websites that
could sell your data and they'll do it
for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection yeah I I don't I I'm
not a big pot smoker I don't drink much
I you know we were talking about smoking
I was I'm trying to stop doing that it
just became like a little bit of a habit
I'm like what the hell you should do the
little black ones too what were they
called cloves no no there's a black
kind of a gel thing that you would pop
uh loot not lose yeah maybe lose yeah
yeah yeah that's so 70s 80s and the
Ecstasy was excellent ecstasy was back
in the day oh no no no no no no no I
didn't try exits the until
the 90s
and I was actually within San Francisco
I'm not gonna say what I was doing
but I was doing a movie in San Francisco
and somebody said oh you got to try this
it's called X
because all the pills would work with an
eggs right and um so I went sure I'll
try that and honest to God it was like
the best
best feeling ever and you can't ever get
that feeling back well it's not just
that I did get it back a few times in
San Francisco
but you feel like [__] for a few days
chase you are like like nothing phases
this guy no I have kidney stones kidney
stones got me this week yeah stuff like
that gets me like oh man [__] but what
what is kidney I heard kidney stones is
like as bad as pregnancy I would never
insult a Woman by saying it it must be
what it's like to give birth but it's
what it must be like to give birth it's
how what it would hurt I could not agree
well you know you where you where your
kidneys are you're passing one or two
little rocks they're only small how many
times does this happen to you this is my
second time in yeah my whole life do you
have to go to the hospital the first
time I did this time I knew what it was
and so I just I knew I had to just ride
it out
until they dissolve or pass or whatever
but it's bad pain yes Lord you cannot
move fine and it just it's unrelenting
and it's it and I've I apologize to any
women watching who've had children but I
really empathize you must be it must be
a fifth of what they go through yeah but
it's if it's anything like that
what causes it do we know
yeah I don't really want to say
it's kind of like no it's it is it is it
is related to diets and and I'm
notoriously
bad with drinking water
like I should be drinking you know in a
bottle yeah thanks
you know you're supposed to drink like
eight glasses a day I never know this
stuff and you know my grandmother will
be 95 in June and she drinks every day
no she goes like this I always you need
to drink more water I haven't drank
water in 95 years why I look at me
do I need water
you're looking to go a little bit you
look a little dehydrated a little bit
your Skin's a little dry you know but
and when I do drink you know what it is
it just like I know it's great and
everything but it bores me out just
drinking it I start to like nod off
we're drinking water right now
that's amazing you know and so but
recently
because I you know I've been a Horror
Story the last five years in terms of
diet and all that stuff why is that do
you think that do you think that's
psychological do you think that sort of
maybe depression do you think it's
anxiety do you think it's like you know
kind of a just a phase no I think you're
gonna be all of those things and there
can be all those things at the same time
because I I deal with it too with uh you
know you know the smoking and the things
because I'm self-destructive right well
smoking was that why see I just seem to
go from one one Habit to another and
then gonna solve that and then smoking
was my other big advice that I did for
many years and I tried so many times to
quit
I quit I remember once I quit for a year
somebody said go and see this
um he's quite vibrant he won't mind me
plugging him because you guys quite a
success where you're going to carry
Gaynor and Kerry's hilarious I've heard
of them yeah Carrie's hilarious he looks
like a little bird he sits on this chair
and his feet dangle from there from the
chair and it's got like a a big head of
hair and he's a hypnotist he's a
hypnotist he's very intense
and um
he and I was like you can you listen I'm
not susceptible to hypnotism
to be fair the first time he did me I
was like I'm not susceptible that was
out
it did actually yeah it actually kind of
worked
and um and I saw him like three or four
times and I quit smoking which everybody
was completely shocked that I quit
because it was on two packs a day
so I quit for a year and then I was um
I was doing a movie in New York and
we're shooting in the Bronx but I mean
like they're really in the projects in
the Bronx yeah and and they did not want
us there
because we were interfering with the
drug trade and whatever else was going
on there and so we had to wear hard hats
to the set because they'd be throwing
[__] off the out of the windows yeah all
those big high-rise building there and
throw them out of the window and he'd be
ducking stuff you know that they weren't
happy to have you there so we had to get
some some
some guy with a gang leader to go and
negotiate with them to like not do it
while we were shooting and anyway it was
scary you started smoking again there no
it wasn't that so much it was
um it was a small budget and it was
really a a tough schedule
and
maybe one
I've done so much stuff I think I've
only ever had
issues with the director three times
maybe and this was one time and it was a
big one it was what the issue the issue
a little bit we were just
okay here's what happened
Viola Davis
and um
before she was you know Viola she's
massive now yeah and I'm so happy for
her because she's one of the nicest
women I ever worked with in my life
anyway we're doing this movie and it was
pretty low budge and
um I was doing a scene
uh with Viola
and the director
the scene would stop when it's like oh
can you do it um do it again and I'll be
like sure what do you want
because so I'm pretty much like that I
don't mind I love directions yeah money
but he wouldn't he wouldn't say
specifically what he wanted just do it
again just do it again well it might be
a bit different this time
that's how I do it again and this this
happened about four times
and then uh
I said to him like listen I um I mean
you got to be more specific I keep doing
it and I I don't know what you want and
he was very frustrated and he said I I
just want you to do it the way
oh boy the way the guy that did the
auditions
did it in the auditions you mean the guy
who reads I read it yeah the reader the
reader yeah this is what he says to an
establishment he was very frustrated and
this is what he said it came out look I
could see it flying you know like
something's flat in people's mouths and
they're desperately trying to get them
back are you a mind reader first of all
no no but that came out of his mouth and
I and I said to him well look we're
about a weekend you can always get him
get him and he can do it you know if he
was reading the lines better than me
then I suggest you get him I don't want
to screw up your movie I don't get upset
by stuff like that
so I just suggested he get the other guy
and uh and they kind of went downhill
from there
and uh I know
Hayden Panettiere was in it
let me ask you this
oh but continue because you were it had
to do with smoking right yeah and so on
that movie one night you know things
were a bit tough during the film
and um
uh the the other guy I think was
continually doing it better than me
better than me the guy from the reading
and um so one night it's very late like
two or three in the morning and I'm on
the rooftop of one of these one of the
project buildings
and it's just me and a guy a grip is
wrapping up cable
and I see him just like light up
cigarette and I looked at him and I said
you gotta you gotta spare spare one
in my hand I'm going I'm just gonna have
one that's the thing it's not gonna hurt
that's it from that one I was on back on
a pack within a week
isn't that something yeah after one year
adult smoker so then you know exactly
back on this back on the smoking
treadmill good and then finally
yeah what caused you to stop for good
uh
all right
[Music]
I was in an induced coma for through
about five days what yeah what happened
I don't know I really don't know he just
went into a coma oh yeah I I
was fine and then I woke up at a
hospital when was this uh
four or five years ago
that's gonna be the most terrifying
thing for you your family oh it was not
good it was just after my wedding
you had just gotten married I just got
married
and you went into a do you remember
where you were when you did this happen
apparently I was in the house that we
got married and why and was in the house
in Hawaii
and uh the night before had gotten a bit
Rowdy and I'd been throwing some
relatives out
of the house because they were Behaving
Badly and uh I got a retired and I I lay
on the couch apparently and went to
sleep
and it just looked like I was sleeping
and then um my my now wife noticed that
I should have woken up by now and I
hadn't so they um
yeah it kind of looks so short I ended
up uh in a hospital in Hawaii
and I was in induce karma for
like seven days something like that
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy
how are you guys not doing this this is
with the world the way it is
um the stigma there's not stigma on
therapy anymore everyone's talking about
mental health and life and this is good
and this means that you deserve uh
therapy uh for your life in your life uh
it should be a part of everyone's life
if you ask me it's helped me
substantially and uh you know you could
talk about so many things and if you
don't they get bottled up and
unfortunately when they get bottled up
things start to manifest and they become
some other things and uh you know if you
just keep talking to someone as a
professional not me but talking to a
professional you'll see the benefits
quickly
anxious thoughts you know sometimes they
they don't seem like they're going to go
away and uh when you're trying to go to
sleep your mind's racing when you're on
a date you're anxious there's all these
things but talking through them with a
licensed therapist through better help
really will help you Ryan you still work
with Better Health I do and it's been
good it has been good for me yeah I'd
notice you've got your calmer I always
feel better coming out of it I mean I
had one yesterday and I usually uh
supports me through you know the next
until the next time I talk yeah and you
always feel like you have nothing to
talk about and by the end you're like I
can keep talking always every time
therapy and better help give me a place
to get out of my negative thought Cycles
so I can find some mental and emotional
peace if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try
it's all done online just fill out a
questionnaire which takes you a minute
and get matched with a licensed
professional or therapist but you can
change them if you don't like them
at no additional charge it's so easy
it's convenient it's flexible it's it
works to your schedule folks get a break
from your thoughts with better help
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside of you
is brought to you by wondery
Selena Quintanilla was a force of nature
but when a loyal friend betrayed her she
met a fate she never deserved even the
rich is a podcast from wondery that
tells you the stories of the crazy lives
of the greatest family dynasties to pop
culture superstars in their new season
Viva Selena you'll hear how she made a
massive cultural impact and became a
legend the world will never forget all
before her 24th birthday she had already
left a legacy across cultures that would
continue for Generations her huge Talent
was nearly overshadowed by her untimely
death she was shot by a close friend and
Confidant but there's so much more to
Selena's story than her tragic passing
she was kind-hearted Brave and tried her
best to bring joy to everyone in her
life the positivity she put into the
world still carries on nearly 30 years
after her death and she will always be
the queen of Tejano music
enjoy even the rich on the wondery app
or wherever you get your podcasts you
can binge even the rich Viva Selena
right now ad-free on wondery plus get
started with your free trial at
wondery.com Plus
did you lose you have brain damage no no
they didn't know they didn't know
anything they weren't even sure they
were telling her we're not sure he's
coming out of it
and they don't know what caused it
really not really they don't really
they're not really sure
but I think it was like
I run myself pretty hard
do you know like I was I was smoking
then I just I don't sleep much
um you stress what I no I'm not a
stressor but you don't sleep it's weird
it's people that stress usually don't
sleep no I just don't sleep I like the
night
what I find is that
my days are usually like kind of full
with other people's [__] like my [__]
podcast yeah but people you know like
remember my family you know my daughter
whatever
um
feeling the stuff I like to do and so
like I find in my day isn't my day
but whenever it hits midnight and
everyone's going to bed that's my time
and then I can just sit back relax
don't
have to think about work or anyone else
or anyone else
and
it depends you know and initially I
would read
but then then my eyesight started
getting a bit shitty
um and uh I love these stories yeah but
then so I took the documentaries and so
that's all I watch horror movies and
documentaries but the horror movies are
such [__] now that I'm switching to
Western they are so bad they're so bad I
love horror and they're so [__] bad
I've been trying to watch them I could
tell you a couple to watch the only ones
speak no evil yeah like that Watcher
that was good see what was the one where
the girl was in the woods
she was deaf oh yeah hush I liked it
liked it Mike Flanagan directly liked it
a lot I love that you love horror you
got to come to the heart we have a
horror group that watch horror movies
every Tuesday night but we're so
I don't know we're so upset now that
last night we said [__] this Rotten
Tomatoes gives it 99 all the reviews and
we watch it and we're like this is a
piece of [__] it's all the same now so
Kevin in the woods it's so everybody all
I want to do is I hate horror movies
where you know
um uh it's quite obvious you need to get
out of the [__] house and you don't
Joy I don't get it yeah you know it's
like when I'm in the old days where it's
like you know you know what was the
thing about when they in the 70s and 80s
you didn't have like again we go back to
the cell phones and technology so people
just couldn't pick up their phone and
call the cops they couldn't do it ever
so if you're out in the woods or you're
out we're out well they try to recreate
that now they do and it works sometimes
my Signal's not working yeah that's
sober done oh I'm so bad they're gonna
figure something else by the way um you
so you quit after the coma you came out
you stopped smoking yeah absolutely that
was it you're like I'm done how many
yeah that was it and um and if that
doesn't make you quit then you know then
you're on your own
um anyway so I was I was I wasn't
allowed to leave Hawaii
uh for about five weeks I think wow and
I was so desperate I was so desperate to
leave but you know when you go into one
of those uh when you go into a discommer
when I came out
like I could remember almost everything
well the most amazing thing about it was
what I remembered the most is that I had
the most amazing
dreams hallucinations I remember them to
a tea to this day it was so
Fanta when I woke up I said how many
hospitals have I been in because I
thought that I had been to Zurich I'd
been on a private plane flying to
hospitals in Zurich in Germany I thought
I'd done like seven hospitals wow it
felt like eternity in my head no no I
mean it was quite an interesting trip
like and I kept meeting these kind of
bizarre people
in this in that state that I was in it
was very lucid actually and there were
times that
I
would come out of that dream state and I
could see people that I knew but I
couldn't communicate with them
that was a little odd that was like
being stuck inside this glass bowl could
you ever see yourself like lying in a
bed yeah I did because that they say is
like when you're passing or like where
you're almost close to passing a lot of
people will see that and when I saw I
didn't see myself okay so he was always
there myself I was in a German Clinic
and I had this crazy female German
Doctor Who was like Bauhaus kind of
thing
no no change of time but we had this new
treatment for you and it was like this
because I was like what I remember it's
hot all the time right and she said we
have this eye suit that you must put on
it was a blow-up suit that it was very
very chilled but it was quite
uncomfortable cancer it was I stand very
uncomfortable to there it was not made
by Hugo Boss that's for sure you know um
what was I gonna say I I love hearing
those stories and I've seen
documentaries on that stuff and there's
like that what is it called that stuff
that when you die there's a there's this
liquid in your head it's called a a HDT
um yeah I know what you're doing but it
releases and it's no one knows science
like what is this here for DMT DMT TMT
and I have TMT well I had a lot of DMT
going on because I had like I said I
still remember them all quite
specifically it's to the point where
when I woke up I said
um which hospital am I in now I've been
there yeah I've been to Germany's
zurich's I know you've been here here
and that way this one hospital and I was
like get the [__] out nothing everywhere
and
that's crazy yeah but I also like
I guess it was more serious than I gave
a credit for
because I had uh um I had to kind of
learn to walk
again and they said to me you're not
getting out of this Hospital
and so you can walk
without a walker there's a very long
Corridor in the hospital and I said till
the end of that around the corner and
come back again when you couldn't walk
that because I was desperate to get out
once I got cautious I just wanted to go
on you know you're not going anywhere
until you can make that walk
well at that point I could barely get
out of bed
so but every day
I just had it in my head I'm getting out
of here I'm getting this it was my one
thing I hate hospitals so Insurance
willpower you wanted to get out you
wanted to live you wanted it I I
I gotten to the point I think it was
about three weeks in there four weeks in
there and I and I I'd had it I needed to
get out so the day before the doctor
said okay let me see you do it and I
just I missed it I got about halfway
down the hall and couldn't do it so that
night I went to sleep and I went I don't
care if it kills you you were making
that walk tomorrow and I still wasn't
ready to leave the hospital to be honest
and he was very skeptical the doctor and
I made myself walk down that Corridor
and walk all the way back and then sit
on the bed and act like it was no big
deal and he lets you go he did let me go
because he promised me when I could do
that he would wow he didn't want to he
knew I was
you know I'm not probably not ready
so
um that's crazy it was it was really
nuts and really I it was a hard it was
pretty hard start for my my my current
wife yeah I would say do you do you uh
do you still love acting do you love
being unset do you love what you do yes
all the time really still I don't love
everything I'm in
supply of course but I love
I love
[Music]
I love the atmosphere of ascent I love
and some they're not all great but
there's always pockets of people say you
were gravitate towards and I love the
collaborative
atmosphere on a set and I'm not a joiner
in life
at all but on a stand I feel like it's
different I feel like I'm joining I feel
like it's a collaboration
and it kind of especially when people
want to work stuff out
and
I've been asked that before because I
think people think you get jaded or
bored and some people do
but I would never in it for the money I
was never in it for I mean when I
started you know my chances of success
were like you know puppies like
everybody else's I didn't think I didn't
even care about that
I really didn't I went to acting school
I loved acting school
I went to several and
I liked most of them
um and I
just enjoyed getting into a piece of
material and seeing what I could do
different with it
most of that stuff when you're an acting
class so stuff's been done like 900
times so you I would always try to find
something like what way hasn't this been
done and what way can I kind of pick
this apart and maybe reassemble it in a
way that's different or your parents
supportive like your dad was an auto
mechanic right my dad was a mechanic so
my grandfather and I can't imagine it
like if it you know my father didn't
speak to me for years because of the
acting yeah he was that upset with you
absolutely in fact when my when his
friends would say when you know let's
say my father's name was Eddie and they
go uh Eddie how you boys doing you go ah
Jonathan he's going to be a doctor he's
going great uh my brother my son Michael
he works in the business with me and
then he just stop
what people would say what about your
oldest son I need to go
he just was what about when you had
success did it change oh yeah but see
that wasn't any good though because that
didn't was it meaningful not to me well
you kind of like where were you
I didn't say listen I did treat him that
way but I didn't
I didn't
oh yeah I know my father and I had a
at a fairly open combustible
relationship and that's before acting
you know we wasn't great I'm the oldest
son so you know an Italian father the
oldest son is responsible for the other
[__] too he looks like your two
brothers if they [__] up it's your fault
so you they never catch it you catch
everything
and so because yeah apparently according
to him you're supposed to know better
and it's like yeah but I'm 12. how the
[__] should I know better so you got a
lot of pressure on you growing up yeah I
mean it was was he a big guy
this is the thing he wasn't he was about
five foot eight
um he was from
um
um from Calabria
and he was a mechanic and he had hands
like rock he'd been do he went to work
when he was
eight
as a Apprentice mechanic
and where he lived he worked for like
you know those guys in the beginning and
you know when he did something wrong
they would throw spanner at his head you
know like that's how he grew up right
but he so he was tough he was a very
tough man and when he put it he had
hands like rocks
and when he put a hand on you man you
knew it so you got hit oh sure like he
he wouldn't mess around you you messed
around you're gonna get smacked my
father and I
yeah did you ever stand up to him I'm
about to tell you that all right we're
about to tell you that story
now during this time all I wanted in
life I wanted to be a professional
soccer player so all my time was devoted
to playing soccer and so like you know I
I got signed professionally
um as a backup goalkeeper when I was 16.
it was quite young yeah for like a big
league right it was in first right at
the time yeah it was the national league
and um and Adelaide Madeline city
Adelaide City might we were doing that
right before he came like analyzed
Brisbane City Gold Coast Melbourne
Adelaide you know we got an Adelaide
everyone just like you know that's like
uh most serial most serial killers per
capita in the world Adelaide Adelaide
but it's got lovely Parks I've been
there twice have you yeah did you know
about the serial killer I didn't I won't
be returning no go ahead the Torrance
River used to have floaters going down
at all the time
home it did it's interesting because my
wife came with me my my current wife
came with me I called him my current
wife because you never know
and uh my future ex-wife my future ex I
don't think so no it's just current and
uh she's such a good sport you know she
came to Adelaide with me because I was
doing something there
and um
she would without me saying anything
he said I worked for a bit of a run down
by the by the
the river
the the what's the river called I forget
now the Torrance no I don't know what
about no one but it goes through the
city and there's all this listen it's
also one of the most beautifully planned
cities Parks everywhere anyway this city
this river runs through the middle of it
and um there's a particular part of it
that has a pretty dark history
and she would say to me I don't know
what it is I don't like running down
there because it just kind of creeps me
out there's something that I said you
have good instincts many people have
floated right past that bridge
oh my god there was a spade of of of
murders especially of young boys
Jesus a massive amount
um one of the greatest unsolved cases in
Australian history still not solved is a
case called The Beaumont children where
three children three siblings one was
the four
four seven eleven
um they went to the beach because back
then listen you just go went no one yeah
my brother and I used to leave the house
at six in the morning and and didn't
come back till six in the evening right
and God knows what the hell we got up to
you know that was the same way 80s it's
like just be home by 10. just be
whatever yeah yeah just be home for
dinner but so these three kids so these
three kids were were kidnapped for my
crowded Beach
and no one ever saw them again
and they've never caught the guy you
might have my own suspicions because at
one time I wanted to do a movie about it
but I was it was suggested to me that I
should not wow well Bob go back to your
father I want to hear that yeah my
father you're the fight with your father
my father okay so my father like you
know
listen he was a larger than life guy he
everything was extremes for him he was a
mechanic he worked hard but he played
hard he gambled a lot so we all always
broke or flush broke a flush broke a
flush broke a flush all the time so but
you know when he was on a bad not a
drinker
but big smoker but when he would be on a
bad run watch out
no not happy at all and so you know I I
was so in tune with this guy
that when I was a kid like you know
under 10 maybe
we had a gravel driveway and he'd pull
up in the car and I could tell from his
footsteps on the crunch on the gravel
what Moody was in
you get so in tune with what's coming
your way so visual and audible it's like
oh man holy [__] I'd hear that crunch I
was gone you need to get out of the
house anyway so like there were quite a
few times where you know I even as a
here's what happened I'm playing soccer
I'm getting bigger
I'm working out in the gym
I'm like starting to get like really
like you never know now but like I was
starting to get really in good shape
and so I think I was about 16.
and he we got another disagreement about
something because I could never shut up
if he said something I thought it was
stupid I would go well that's just
stupid and uh and that was enough to set
him up
and so he got me up he had me up against
he had me up against he had me
I had a T-shirt and a pair of shorts on
and he had me Buy the T-shirt they had
it ripped up like that like that and I
remember just thinking that's [__] it
no more and I grabbed him and I shoved
him up against the wall
and I said you never [__] touching me
again and he his eyes I've never it's
like Marty Feldman they came out of his
head and you think that was the end of
it [__] no there was a big not a carving
knife on the table
so he grabs the knife what and he starts
coming after me with it are you serious
100 and if you'd have caught me you
would have stabbed me but I I knew it
too because at that moment I realized
that maybe pushing him up against him
well wasn't that great an idea
so I I God so I ran it's like cartoon I
ran through uh we had a screen door and
I ran through the screen door through
the screen like like my shape was in the
in the screen uh and it was nighttime
and I took off
I had no shoes on I had a rip t-shirt
down the middle and I'm walking around
the streets of my neighborhood right
thinking oh Jesus I don't know where I'm
going I know where to go you know I just
can't stay out here for a bit I guess
and then this cop car pulls up next to
me there
what's going on
what do you what are you what are you
doing out here I said no I'm just taking
a walk it's about one in the morning I'm
just taking a walk and then how do you
rip your T-shirt I said oh you know I
just it's ripped just like that already
and um they kind of got it they knew so
they got they said where do you live and
I said yeah get in the carb and then
we've got to my house they said do you
want us to come in
and I said no I think I'll be all right
and um so they dropped me off they got
they knew and what did Dad do when he
got out we could think right if the
house is dark it's gonna be like two in
the morning by now house is dark and I
think he's gone to bed that's great
so I kind of go in the house quietly and
I get to my room and I open the door and
all I see is this little bright orange
tip of a cigarette in the corner just
it is like you back huh and I'm like yep
he said we're gonna talk about this in
the morning and he left
oh my God but he never he never touched
me again
you know my friend Joe has a story just
like that like his dad would always do
this he said he had a finger that was
steel and he'd poke him in his chest and
it would hurt and he'd lay in and one
time he did it and Joe grabbed his
finger and said
never touch me again yeah because he had
grown he was wrestling and all that I've
heard that story many times
unfortunately I was the shortest I was
so I was five foot four when I graduated
high school my dad was six five two five
four I grew nine inches or eight inches
in the next year on my way to college
wow but my daddy I couldn't do that I
tried to stand up to him but like what
am I yeah I mean it was just impossible
I I didn't have the size I didn't have
the you know what I mean but uh it was
interesting it was an interesting change
in dynamic
he's still our relationship wasn't any
better
but that part of it was over and the
interesting thing is
he never did that with either of my
other two brothers just you made an
example because um there was it's a
thing in Italian families were the
oldest
supposed to take responsibility for all
[__] from the age of nine years old and
I figured it out later in life he went
to work when he was eight
so for him your childhood ended at eight
or nine
that's it wow you know you got to be
more responsible did you do you look
back and think I love my Dad it was
tough but or was it when he passed were
you I was there was it hard
I want to be honest no
wasn't no
he
had
um cancer
and he um
he had had a
they did this arthroscopic surgery on
him two years before
and they said that you know they came
the doctor came out
and said look
of we got I think we got most of it a
lot of it but
I think it's going to come back in maybe
two years
should we tell him and we all said no no
downtown
let him feel like and because if you
told them you'd think about it well I
know my none of my dad he would have
obsessed on it
so
um let me tell him
and um he's quite happy
but to the day two years later he came
back and there was no fixing it this
time
and uh my father was a guy that did not
want to die
at all how old was he I want to stay
late 70s late 70s
I'm not that far away from him he he he
just did not want to go
and he was so pissed off
because his mental Factory such as it
was was still there and but his body was
starting to phylum and
it's just some really interesting stuff
and I went back and all my brothers will
dropped everything we've done it several
times we've gotten these calls before
you know you're you're old man's dying
come back and we go back and he'd be
fine you know like you'd make a recovery
right so it's a bit of a joke but this
time we knew it wasn't so the two of us
three of us went back
and um
he did not want to die in a hospital so
we got him out of the hospital we took
him out
and um
it was just really uh it was
our relationship this is the thing I
think you have it's part of you as a kid
you know part of me felt like
oh this is the moment where
we reconcile this is the moment where he
tells me you know I'm sorry about all
the [__] that I did and all that
kind of stuff
and
it just never came
and I have to tell you something I was
relieved
that it didn't come
because I wouldn't have known what to do
with it
I wouldn't have known who that guy was
never who that's never who he was he was
Unapologetic
to the end it just was that way and so
we sent that difficult relationship
brought up right up to the last day
you know like there was a time when he
was in hospital my two brothers were
there and and he's in this enormous
amount of pain and he's taking
um
uh Advil
they've given him every great drug known
to man to kill the pain and he won't
take it don't believe in them
the drugs that I said just tell me where
they are because I'll take them no
problem I don't want to watch this right
you know what I mean so we got into a
fight One Night in the hospital and uh I
said to him you know this is driving me
nuts you could there's pain medication
it's it's designed to you have to suffer
like this I'm not [__] taking it
and I said well I'm not gonna I don't
feel like watching it so I I left the
hospital room and um just to tell you
everything about my dad it's brilliant
I have respect for my dad
um so my second brother comes down
I said the dagger for all comfortable
walk with you just let me go up and talk
dad for a minute so he goes up and he
talks to my father and uh he comes down
he said um Dad tell me to give you a
message
and I said what's that he said he told
me go [__] yourself
[Laughter]
but it was it was it was a very hard
boring relationship do you think though
if you in your gut do you think
I know my father loved me in his own way
or do you not really believe that
it's interesting I've never always asked
me that question before
I guess on some level yeah
but uh we just did not
have a
that kind of relationship no which is
what it was that's how it was it was
what it was it was like um
I you know I could have been a 40 year
old mechanic that worked alongside of
them and it wasn't changed not really I
don't think so but my brothers have a
totally different experience with him
so sometimes we fight about
you know the the perception of my father
right right and and and uh and I don't
[__] with them they fight with me I'm
like Hey listen it's easy for you guys
to say I was I was accomplishing [__]
for your [__] so of course it was fine
for you yeah um but I also don't hold it
against them either right I don't have
I don't have feelings of resentment
against him or yeah
I did have those feelings yeah sure me
too
my initial impetus like to succeed
in anything yep was because my father
told me all the time approval my father
told me on a daily basis that I would
never amount to [__]
on a pretty daily basis
and um and so internally knob is he was
good for me internally I'd be like
really we'll see [__]
we will see and um
and so that drove me I think in the
first part of my career
that really was like the rocket fuel
I could say it now I don't think I
realized it so much at the time
but you're almost like thank you for
that
in a way it was an unintentional gift
but yeah it hardened me up for a
business the
you need to have some hide
this is not an easy business
I love you know look reality shows and
stuff it's kind of diluted
the difficulty of like really being an
actor
and the amount of content in the
streaming services taking it out of you
know what I mean look I have nothing
against reality I can't really watch it
because I'm just not interested in the
boring [__] that they're talking about
right right they're just talking about
like such minutiae problems well they've
like you know sucking on a 95 carat
diamond ring or something it's like I
don't [__] care no I know I just
don't care about your problem yeah and
um you don't have one you know and I
won't mention the obvious to sit around
eating salads sounding like cats all the
time
we haven't really talked about your
career yeah but that's not what the
podcast is I like to talk about life and
[__] yeah like I know you want to look
you want a Tony and a Golden Globe and
an Emmy is there that that sort of ego
that's like I want an Oscar and then I
want him then I got them all 100 100
want that I would love it
I have to earn it
but I would love that
absolutely I won't lie
yeah I watched the when you won your
Golden Globe and I just you just look so
happy and confident like so appreciative
too it was nice they didn't see me win
the Tony it was so much different oh
really no I was like I was so not sure I
was so sure I was not winning that
that year that when it when they called
my name I swear to God it was at Radio
City Musical and it was like you know
you see movies where they do like the
amorphic lens and everything goes that's
exactly what happened to me so I go on
stage I forgot to thank the director I
forgot of course Allison Jetty I forgot
I don't know what the [__] I said uh
it's just like this the whole blur
and um
but
it meant a lot yeah of course it means a
lot to me you know what it is for me I
haven't won many awards I mean words
that aren't like you know Saturn award
it wasn't a Golden Globe was it but you
know what it's an acknowledgment exactly
I think it was just like hey someone saw
something in me that they appreciated
that's nice to know that I'm doing
something right yeah and I like as I
said when I started I didn't I had no
expectations of even working
so everything that's had everything that
happened was there was that weird thing
that happened in the beginning when
you're younger
like I went from
seven or eight years of
AG theater classes and doing off off off
into the river in New Jersey Broadway
New Jersey Broadway some you know I did
I can't remember the theater was so
small there was an actor named Bobby
Pastor really I don't remember if you
remember Bobby
was an amazing actor he used to play
Eldon on Murphy Brown
yeah yeah I do remember him so Bobby was
a real
he was a great friend of mine and he was
kind of like that's a I have a bunch of
tattoos and
I I got my first tattoo
because Bobby said hey Anthony you want
to go to uh Paterson New Jersey we're
gonna get a tattoo from my tattoo artist
Calamity Jane and I'm like sure Bobby
I'll go so I go I'm not intending to get
a tattoo and Bobby's laying on the chair
and he's getting a giant wolf
at the Moon on his chest he had tons of
tattoos already right right and he's
like and he's laying there and he looks
like he's in no pain whatsoever none
right and he's going nah and he's
chatting and wagging he's laughing with
me and whatever
and he says hey you want to get a tattoo
I'm buying I'm like yeah come on okay
what just a little one get a little one
get them on your arm you see yeah look
at that wall man pick one off the wall
and so I'm looking at these you know
like I don't know [__] from you know
about tattoos and so I look at one and
it's like it's a dagger with a snake
and it's something else something about
like that big right
and so I'm thinking I'll get that small
be okay whatever I get in the chair I
cry like a [__] in Christ that is
sweating
I started going to a flop sweat like the
pain was relentless it went in it
wouldn't light up and he just sat with
you laughing his ass off but like he was
he was such a funny great guy I love
that do you still keep in touch with
like you know certain actors from
certain projects like uh Empire Records
do you still talk with any of those guys
or was that kind of like uh because that
was such a great cast you've been in so
many things with gray cast I wonder
because I met your best friend what's
his name
out here which one the one out here
who's waiting for you oh hurry yeah Rory
Jorge Jorge George George
um and you guys have been friends 20
years and it seems to me like you know
you don't have a lot of actor friends
you like you know you don't you don't do
you no and it's not because I don't like
them the truth is
once you all start working look okay so
there was a time in New York but I would
walk into an audition room before any of
us started booking and it would be
John saturo May Stanley 2G and Vince
Banner and another guy I can't remember
Platt
no it was different we're different we
were all we were all tired so we're all
the Italians gotcha and it got to the
point where we walk in the room and we
go ah you're here well one of us gets it
right you know and one of us would get
it you know and it would kind of rotate
around right
and um I'm still friends from then with
Stanley did she
um although he's like he's blown up so
big now
he lives in London
he's got a beautiful wife a bunch of
kids and
um so his life is
you know sorry people get busy people
have their own lives
well I do I visit him sometimes when I
go to London I go have dinner with him
and his wife and stuff but
but there's not a regular
there's not a regular thing
because
you're all on different schedules
and but I'm the kind of person like if
you're my friend
if I don't see you for a year or two
years it's okay yeah I don't get upset
about it and when I see you it's like it
picks up where it left off yeah a lot of
people don't feel the same way
a lot of people get upset if you don't
return a phone call or
yeah I hate that you got to be
understanding just like hey I'm here I'm
not I have to admit I mean if you had
the right friends you don't reach out as
much I'm not I don't you know how to
reach you're not a Jack Reacher I'm not
I'm actually I'm really happy with my
own company yeah yeah yeah I'm not like
I don't I don't you don't need a lot of
people
very few you need you need it to be
night when everybody else goes to bed
yeah you need a you know Jorge hang out
no who already doesn't hang out he
doesn't no no no no he sleeps
everybody's sleeping everybody's not
even him everybody all right listen to
this this is called chick talking with
Anthony lapalia this is my top tier
patrons that get back to the podcast
they're devoted die hards I couldn't do
without them this is rapid fire take a
drink of coffee coffee so this is going
to be I'm gonna ask a question it's
rapid fire you answer fast okay
um thank you go to patreon.comcity thank
you guys you know I love you all right
Katie B Mr lapalia by the way how many
people say Mr La Paglia yeah everyone
okay all right that was my question by
the way Mr apollya had an epic guest run
on Fraser and I saw it what was it like
stepping into that and working with that
tight group of actors amazing that
accepted me right away from the first
reading I got laughs and they kept
writing the part bigger for me and you
won an Emmy and I want an Emmy
Maya P what is your advice for
maintaining longevity in the business
let go
when you up for project when you read
something you really like and you know
that you could play it and you know all
that stuff an actors think
when it doesn't go your way
give yourself
that afternoon
and Let It Go
and move on to the next thing be like be
like a shark I love it House of Joelle
what are the crazy memories from Empire
Records and do you have a favorite song
from that great soundtrack oh my God my
craziest memories I have were of uh was
we were at a CVS or something like that
and those kids were nuts Rory Cochran
Rory was actually one of the saner ones
but Ethan he want mommy saying this I
sometimes I still text Ethan but like
Ethan Embry and um the other kid
um I see him too he's grown up he's
pretty good yeah oh Johnny Whitworth I
don't know I know I don't hear from
Johnny much it's the other he had a
smaller role and this kid I remember him
so well because he drove a golf cart I
had a brand new
um a brand new Ford uh Bronco right and
in the first week of shooting him what
was his name Sean um
no no Brennan Sexton yes Brendan Sexton
yeah I worked with him too I love
Brendan I worked with them years ago
Brendan Jackson is a great kid yeah
anyway he destroyed my my broker with a
golf cart like the second day I had it
did you want to kill him yeah kind of
um but um the the craziest stuff I
remember
is Ethan and it might have been Brendan
Ethan is someone else we were out of CVS
um Ethan got a hold of like a a fake gun
it was orange an orange fake gun in the
CVS might have been a flare gun or
something and he ran out into the
parking lot and was like pointing at
people the next thing I know I walk
outside and you know just in North
Carolina so the North Carolina State
Troopers then I [__] around
they had those boys on their back on
their on their stomachs to the handcuffs
and in jail
they went to jail in that that day and
and and
the producer I forget his name poor guy
who's the flare gun
but like everybody got freaked and I'm
just standing there watching the whole
thing but this has been going on they've
been [__] around for the whole movie
you know so this is not a big surprise
so I'm just standing back watching it
thinking that might straighten you out
it didn't but um
that's amazing yeah and his favorite
song from it
you know I never watched the things I'm
in so I don't really remember
uh let's see if your child tell us the
other car I tell you what did you
remember live Tyler
was probably one of the nicest human
beings I never met in my life
she was so sweet and so completely
genuine and this is I think before she
found out like
who her dad was
um
I think that was just happening or
something really she didn't know no she
didn't know Stephen I didn't know that
no she didn't no I'm oops well I'm sure
that that I think I think I think was it
Todd Rundgren brought her up and and
but um I didn't think that at the time
you know I remember her being incredibly
sweet
I'm looking at the songs here are you
looking at him no I was looking him too
again
um it was a good soundtrack I think yeah
oh my God Jim blossoms Toad the Wet
Sprocket oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that stuff from back there
cracker love cracker this was like uh
but the movie the movie was just like a
free-for-all it was it was fun it was
you know what
this is the thing
this is angry Anthony right because and
you can't tell in the movie but I was
not a happy camper because
the movie when I got the script it was
like full of like
drug references and smoking dope and
people getting high and all this stuff
director Allen no it wasn't the studio
the day before we started shooting the
studio went we're taking all that stuff
out it's PG now
and uh and the kids were like ah [__] it
they didn't care whatever they didn't
know but I was like wait this changed
the entire like movie this was it was
not a musical when I started it
and and so it took me a while to wrap my
head around the fact that I'm now in a
completely different film than the one I
thought I was trying to get out of it no
but I was not happy that you know
um I was committed to it and so I
thought I'm gonna do my best to make it
work and it took me a a week or two
and then you know what what really kind
of I I shot me the most was the director
Alan Moyle who was trying to make that
okay instead of saying to me look it's
[__] up
it's not Direction I'm going to go in he
got a little happy
you know hell I'm gonna make a fantastic
movie anyway and there was and I was
like and I was like uh you know it's so
uh
and you know this Renee Zellweger was in
it and these were all kids that were all
really talented but they needed
Direction
and I remember doing this thing look at
me telling these dirty stories I
remember being in a scene in the film we
were all the record store and we
rehearsed it no we got any rehearse it
Alan wants to shoot it and so we shoot
it and the kids all line up against the
wall don't move and say they're lying
standing against the wall it doesn't and
all no doubt and I'm walking around the
office and then it was cut and he goes
all right that's not bad let's go go
ahead what do you mean that's not bad
nobody's doing anything you got to give
them an attention give them an action
give them something to do
not before we had like a good good
yelling match
you try to tell me how to direct my
movie I said yes yeah actually actually
I am and I never do that stuff yeah I
know I heard the nicest best guy to work
with for many people I never do that
stuff and and it's only when I see some
confidence we're not lack of caring well
just he wanted to be friends with every
with all the young actors so much that I
think that it it distracted him
I don't think he's a bad director I just
think he
I know what you're saying and he also
enabled them
with their bad behavior a little bit and
um that kind of that didn't sit well
with me either listen I I
even when I started
I started with you know really kind of
serious people
Kim Stanley
you know was one of my acting coaches
just war was one of the most amazing
actresses on stage in New York ever
people who were old enough still
remember performers in the three sisters
in 1963 you know that's someone who
really
and I got I was lucky I got to study
with a few people like that and that the
seriousness
of what you were doing
was always impressed upon me not
necessarily by telling me but for the
environment that I was in and it wasn't
like wanky oh aren't we so great actors
it was like no this is work let's do the
work let's do the work let's really
focus there's nothing wrong with that no
no and that's that's the only thing when
I work on a set I'm very procrew I love
the crew because they work their asses
off they get there first they leave they
leave last yeah I got the easy job I
usually have if I ever have issues it's
more with upper management creative or
whatever real quick yeah not even
created the creatives are usually not
bad it's upper management above that who
are like
you know my argument always is look we
can do it and it's a bit darker but it's
really good we could do it in the light
and [__] I don't know which one do you
want
you know whichever saves US money moving
on and that's what really gets me it's
like I want quality yeah let me ask you
this yeah go and this is a quick
question I have to know this Ryan I have
to know is this a true story that you
were casting Django Unchained and you
left because it was out of control or is
that just [__] that's [__] it is
I was casting it but I couldn't do it
why is that because
I'm Quince listening because I loved him
all right yeah I love him I loved him
and I went in and I read with Jamie Foxx
we did readings and stuff and I was so
pumped to do it right and
what happened was they had problems on
Django they kept pushing they kept
pushing them apart they kept pushing my
part and I pushed it for like months and
then I got another job
and and then as soon as I got that job
we're ready for you Queen is ready for
myself like quite like uh
I said I have to not do it because
before you told me you were ready I
committed to this other job thinking
that this was going to continue
nobody told me that you were close to
heated though did you talk to him about
it he never I don't think he ever spoke
to me again
I bet he forgot about it now I bet it's
okay now yes he has a pretty amazing
memory
like he knew all my movies well I bet he
I bet he's forgiving and understood and
maybe didn't call you or talk to you
about it but it was disappointing
I got the sense that he was upset that I
he felt like I made the wrong choice
that I sort of by then it was a film
it was an Australian film that had got
all its funding based on my name right
so I really I sat there and kind of did
The Logical math where I liked to be in
in one of Quentin's movies of course I
would
but this movie if I pull out of it
they're going to lose their financing
and I felt responsible to that I knew me
not being in Django print wasn't going
to lose one cent no financing because I
wasn't in it let me ask you this lastly
I got to ask you this and I'll let you
know because I know you can ask me by
the way this is awesome your stories are
just [__] awesome thank you I
appreciate it I mean I I was like
again with one of those guys I go all
right he's got to come back he's got so
many stories we'll get into it yeah
anytime seriously but um scratched the
tip of the eyes I know it's I just I
touched on a little a little a lot of a
little things but but some important
things like I like the stuff the
relationship in your dad all that but I
wanted to ask you because I know you
worked with them and I know a lot of
things came out I forgive my dad by the
way just just so you know yeah so yeah
so you know at the end I I I'm so much
forgave but understood
accepted well especially last year
I went back to his village
where he grew up and everything made
sense
wow in bubbalino in uh in Calabria in
Italy and the people in bovillino
welcomed me to that town like I was a
returning Warrior
I got a key to the city oh my God I know
and I thought oh my dad could see this
he'd be pissed you'd be so pissed off
that idiot don't get the [__] off that
idiot gonna get in the city I busted my
ass
all right so you worked with Bill Murray
on Broadway didn't you
oh no okay here's what happened I did uh
after
the World Trade Center World Trade
Center I did a play Bill Murray was
doing a play with Sigourney Weaver it
was it's more of a reading kind of play
but it was quite powerful it's called
the guys right and I got a call
um
saying
because Susan's husband Jim he's a
theater guy and I got a call saying
um we'd like to come in and replace Bill
he's got to leave oh good
you can't really replace bill
and um
um I was like yeah sure
and then Susan Saron came in with me to
replace Sigourney
um I'm not sure so you're not sure
you're actually you never really you
never worked with him I've never read my
bill I would have loved to have but I
mean even now I know he's in trouble and
[__] but whatever yeah people are in
trouble
um people get in trouble for bad actions
people get in trouble I don't listen
here's the thing about
um reporting and hearsay
um I find it not to be particularly
reliable there's two sides of the story
I'm not ever saying
um if there are complaints from women
about being harassed I take that
seriously
I had heard that
but I always heard in this kind of like
affectionate curmudgeoning way that bill
was a bit grumpy
he's also one of my favorite movies of
all time
Lost in Translation oh yeah I love that
movie and I think his performance is
incredible no no doubting is a brilliant
actor yeah but I had her I had heard he
was a bit commodity and all that stuff
and I'm like whatever Richard Dreyfuss
supposedly said he was a monster on What
About Bob a monster I I I I don't
no no he's the most highly energetic
enthusiastic actor actor friendly guy
I really enjoyed working with him did
you have you ever worked with any and
you know what to say but just any
[__] any guys like that are big
stars at your likes this son of a [__]
I'm just gonna do my part I'm gonna do
what I do and [__] him [__] her whatever
it is no no
no I replaced somebody who was an
[__] and I heard about it
what an [__] he was I'm not saying
who it was
um
but I have never worked with someone
that I've worked with some difficult
people
like I worked with at that time he had a
reputation and I'll say because I love
him Val Kilmer right and I worked with
Val and this is a true story on the
first day that I meet Val
he comes out and he's wearing he's got
like this pristine white t-shirt that
says uh
what was that movie he did with DeNiro
uh
heat hey he's got a beautiful white he
t-shirt and he's got a cup of coffee
and I'm standing there talking to the
director and he comes up and I've got
like this kind of like I don't know like
nylon uh jacket or something
and he comes up he's got a cup of coffee
he puts his arm around me and starts
pouring the coffee down the front of my
jacket while I'm talking to the director
and I'll just look at it and I just get
it and I just wipe it all over his nice
white T-shirt
set up a good relationship really yeah I
didn't get upset I just wiped my coffee
back on his T-shirt and and
I think a lot of people and he probably
would have even said he was I mean
touche having a pretty difficult time at
that time yeah and he there was some big
blow-ups on that said and but me
personally I didn't have a problem
with him that's awesome and and you know
he would come into my trailer and he
would say things to me like now listen
man I want you to
um see these spring he had all these big
rings on he's like I think that you
should wear it this ring
in this scene because it represents X Y
and Z and blah blah blah and now what I
know is the shot we're about to do
is the three of us standing on a hill in
silhouette against the Sun so I go give
me the room that's great no one gives a
[__] what's good it made him happy and
you know it made him happen man this is
this has been awesome I I loved I love
these stories I loved having you you
didn't know me for [__] no I'm a mutual
friend you ask great questions I have to
say oh thanks I I just wanted to hear
your story and you have such a story so
I I appreciate it I I I'm gonna keep in
touch with you I've been real lucky in
in my own whole career well here's to
you getting an Oscar someday do you know
what I would love it if it doesn't
happen but I I'm on your gravestone
short of the phone I don't no I'll just
make my own and put it on the top I I
[Music]
it's something that like
um I know people go like our Awards and
blah blah blah anybody says the word
doesn't mean anything they're a liar
because it's nice to be acknowledged by
your peers sure and it's
it
I'm going to look for a lot of a lot of
actors Oscars like kiss of death for a
couple of years because what happens to
I know I've known a couple people what
happens is they win the Oscar and they
go
it happened to me when I wanted to tell
me I went what do I do now how do I top
this
I didn't do theater for like a bunch of
years
because I didn't know how to top it you
don't try to top you just continue to do
good work I didn't I I know I'm just
saying that's what you probably should
do that's exactly what you should do I
don't know that's exactly what you
should do but we're going to take your
coughs out too by the way thank you yeah
Jason make sure it's off so you hit me
with kidney stones and [__] make sure
you edit that all right we can leave
them in I don't care no whatever I love
you thanks for coming out thank you for
having me I really enjoyed this
all right there you go there you have it
I hope you love the episode if you did
please write a review
get on our socials join patreon support
the podcast I love you thanks for just
being here
um and if you missed out on a lot of
stuff I talk about the live podcast
inside you we're doing with Zach Levi
October 11 7 P.M don't miss that it's
going to be great at the Regent Theater
in Los Angeles Ryan you'll be there yes
it will yeah in some capacity I would
hope so yeah we're figuring that out now
also forgot to mention this Sun spin my
band is playing September 16th 5 PM
Pacific Standard Time
we'll read your messages as we're
playing well maybe make a song of them
there's prizes there's zooms there's
good music we're going to be playing all
our greatest hits from our three albums
the ones that are most popular to people
fans and I hope you join us if you
haven't listened to a concert I think
you'll really enjoy it so just get out
of your comfort zone and do it
let's go to sunspin.com also if you want
merch signed lexmith scripts and other
things
uh hoodies
go to in the inside of you online store
and get your fun merch there's a lot of
cool stuff and sunspin.com has an
amazing amount of new merch there too
um lastly I'm going to give the shout
outs right yeah
and these shout outs are from patrons
who support the podcast
um in more ways than one they don't just
listen
they listen to almost every episode if
not all of them if they're you know
they're loyal listeners and they they
give back to the podcast which is
unbelievable and if you want to join
them if you like the podcast and you
want to support it because it's it's you
know I feel like it's NPR it's like you
get people to kind of give to the
podcast but it's true it's like to keep
it going I couldn't do it without my
patrons patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com inside of you join
today uh tons of perks you'll see them
and I'll give you a shout out and I'll
also
yeah I'll give you a shout out I'll
email you right there just like that
actually just a little just a little
just like that just like that just a
little email now it's time for the top
tiers of the patreon they get the shout
outs and no particular order they're all
amazing people here we go
Ryan ready I'm ready I got them here
I'll do uh a voice and then Ryan has to
do that impression it's gonna be tough
because I'm my posture in this new couch
is uh you don't like it well I'm trying
to figure it out okay maybe maybe I need
pillow you know what I'm good now you're
good now I'm good all right
y Liam Kristen
we go Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophia Rasheen Joshua
Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F general b
Chanel B sure
Eldon Supremo 99 more
Santiago M Chad w
Leanne Matias Belinda and Dave a Sheila
G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom n
Talia and Betsy D Angel amerian and C
Corrie K devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy d
illian Eugene and Leah Corey Angela F
Mel s Christine s
Eric H Shane R Andrew M Amanda R
between Michael Jackson
Jen B Kevin B Stephanie K Charelle Jim
and Jay Lee NJ Luna R Mike F Stone Age
Caleb
stay Wild
Brian l l
[Music]
and Jessica B
Kyle
[Laughter]
I'm out Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F Marion
Louise L Romeo B Veronica Q Frank B Jen
T Nikki L April R Derek n j d w
Ong Ginger Insomniac Rachel D and
Lorelei L is that the end that's the end
I don't even have those on here really
yeah I don't know why oh they're on the
back page oh yeah you know what they're
on the back page
oh Lorelei
how are you good to see you shout out oh
man why guys thanks so much for
listening and making this podcast part
of your week and uh hopefully you'll
continue listening
that's about it for me uh Michael
Rosenbaum here in the Hollywood Hills of
California Ryan I'm Ryan I'm here too in
the Hollywood Hills of California
a little way to the camera which is now
lower yeah the camera's lower now we
have it lower we have a different angle
tell us if you like the new angles or
experiments we're experimenting the
furniture's different uh give us your
feedback we'd appreciate it and most
importantly be good to yourself I will
see you very soon I cannot wait Ryan be
careful the mic stand
[Music]